so maybe walk us through what is the
problem with inflation and then what
should people be doing well the
frustrating thing to me is that the
people on mainstream news and our
politicians aren't being honest about
not only the fact that we have inflation
but what causes it so i'm hoping to use
my skills that i acquired being in
mainstream news to hopefully educate the
public on money printing and the fact
that you know in the last year 40 of the
dollars that are in circulation were
printed and there's a reason that the
prices are going up and there's you know
certain people that are benefiting i
don't know if you saw that article on
cnbc that private jets like there's a
record number of private jets being sold
right now the rich are getting richer
meanwhile it's hard to buy milk at the
store for the average person so you know
i just think it's really important to
tell the truth and it's frustrating when
you see
you know the politicians sort of denying
that inflation even exists or they act
shocked economists are shocked that 6.2
percent is the is the rate that they're
admitting to and um i just hope that
people educate themselves and bitcoin's
the perfect way to educate yourself
because it really helps you go down the
rabbit hole of of economics in our
monetary system
and when you think about uh the
disparity between the top let's say 10
the bottom 90 percent is it something
that can be solved with things other
than bitcoin or is it literally they
have to use something like bitcoin that
can't be debased as that savings account
in order to protect themselves well i
think that's what's so great about this
being a savings technology and a form of
digital property that nobody can
confiscate from you because at this
point i feel like we're just kicking the
can down the road and we can't fix this
problem unless it's going to be a very
painful crash to unwind some of the
leverage that we have so at this point
it's like they're stuck between a rock
and a hard place they can either hike
you know interest rates and they could
taper but it could it would be very very
painful or they're going to lead us into
hyperinflation so you know this is a
great way to just opt out i truly
believe that bitcoin is that peaceful
way to opt out for anyone to be able to
start accumulating wealth for their
family again we used to be able to put
our money in the bank and get what like
six percent a couple decades ago well
now with bitcoin what you could get like
300 in a year i think it's amazing and i
hope that more people educate themselves
on it
you've talked to a ton of what i'll call
normie friends right people who know
nothing about bitcoin that you know from
uh your professional life or social
circles and you've done a great job kind
of orange pilling them what's the
narrative that you see really resonating
with them in terms of how they wake up
to whether it's inflation or to uh
bitcoin itself
well i really think that the recent
headlines have helped with you know
inflation being 6.2
and just seeing the fact that
everything's getting so much more
expensive and then when you
it in bitcoin terms everything's getting
cheaper and cheaper so i think that
those you know
those references in the media have
started to help and i try to put out
there just sort of that basic knowledge
of what is money printing and why it
helps the upper class as opposed to the
the income earners and the savers and
the middle and the bottom classes so
yeah and honestly i've been really
surprised because as i've put myself out
there more i wasn't able to do this when
i had my network job people have started
to ask me more questions and said hey
you know i actually ended up
investing in bitcoin and it was because
of you you inspired it so i'm super
grateful because some of the people that
were the most skeptical on my feeds and
who followed me especially from my old
career now they're starting to be like
hey what was that app that you wanted me
to buy bitcoin on or
so it's been great i think it's you know
slowly but surely it's inevitable
and when you start to think about how
people come into the market do you see
them dollar costs averaging like 10 20
30 at a time do you see them coming in
and being like hey here's a hundred
thousand dollars i'm all in like
what is the kind of those first steps
that people are taking after you
convince them
most of them are putting in like a
hundred bucks
um no i think that a lot of them are
starting with dca just because the price
looks so intimidating and overwhelming
you know some people i'm sure can can
drop the 50 to 60 000 for one whole
bitcoin but what i'm noticing is people
are just like slowly inching their way
in dipping their toes in the water with
a couple dollars or a couple hundred
dollars and i'm sure that it will
continue especially the the way that
we're headed now i'm pretty sure this
variant is gonna spark the money printer
to just go even faster eventually so
yeah i think dca all the way
and speaking of uh kind of the monetary
policy and fiscal policy in response to
more of these variants more of these
viruses
i'm not a scientist i don't know what
the hell is going on but it seems like
people are really nervous again uh is
that just the standard is that the
default now is every time something like
this happens we should expect uh some
sort of manipulation or intervention in
the economic markets
well i'm i'm certainly starting to
expect that because they were just
slowly starting to mention the t word
you know taper people i think we're
expecting it early next year but with a
variant and the potential for more
lockdowns and more you know economic
activity that's slowing because of the
pandemic
continuing on and on i mean what we're
almost going to be two years in march i
just think that the response is going to
be you know keep the bubble afloat and
print more money and that's always a
good value proposition for bitcoin
because the more that they print the
more that i think people realize that
the system is broken and it's a total
sham and there's nothing behind it like
where's the wizard you know so i just
think it's going to ultimately help
bitcoin but i do i really believe that
the money printer is going to go bur
even more if we have a variant that's
going to lock people down again
countries in europe already are locking
down so i just think that's the
direction we're headed in